-Hot crowd.
Hot New York City crowd tonight.
Guys, speaking of New York,
did you hear that --
I just saw the Knicks fired
their head coach this week?
-Whoo!
-I heard, yeah!
-Yeah. You did hear it, ma'am?
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-She heard.
-Knicks fans were shocked.
They were like, "We had a coach?
[ Laughter ]
"What was he doing?"
I want to say congratulations to
Khloe Kardashian,
who gave birth
to a baby girl yesterday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The baby has 10 fingers,
10 toes,
and 10 million Instagram
followers.
It's very -- Yeah, already.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's sweet.
-Hey, guys, Tuesday is tax day,
which means you've got just
three days left
to either send in your taxes
or become President of America.
So it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Tax day is coming up.
What's nice about tax day
is whether you're getting
a refund or not, we're all going
to go out and get drunk
and buy something we don't need.
It's just perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I don't need it."
The deadline for filing
your taxes is on Tuesday,
and a lot of Americans still
haven't even gotten started yet.
So here with last-minute tips
on doing your taxes
from the independent financial
consulting firm,
Bream and Hackett,
here's Mark Bream.
Thank you for being here, Mark.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Nice to be here.
-Now, Mark, April 17th is right
around the corner.
What are tips you have
for people who still
haven't started their taxes
this late in the game?
-That's a good question,
Jimmy. Eh, don't worry about it.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry. What?
-Yeah.
Don't worry about doing
your taxes.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
-Yeah, you know.
Don't do 'em. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. Right. What do you mean,
don't do your taxes?
Just don't do them?
-Yeah. Don't do 'em.
You're good.
[ Laughter ]
-Good? But if you don't file
your taxes,
don't you risk
getting in trouble?
-Nah, you're good.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry. I'm just a little
unclear here.
Do you guys have some sort of
system or process
for helping people
with their taxes?
-Oh, yes, we do, Jimmy.
Step one, yeah...
[ Laughter ]
Step two...
-I'm so sorry, Mark.
Can you please explain
yourself further?
I think we're all a little
unclear here.
-Well, Jimmy, we here
at Bream and Hackett have found
over the years that we don't
really understand taxes at all.
[ Laughter ]
Like, we don't get them.
Like, we don't know what a 1040
is or W-2 or W-4
or why there's a "W."
[ Laughter ]
Like, we heard the phrase
"estimated tax,"
but we have no clue
what it means.
Like, like,
we've heard about FICA,
but we just think it's the name
of someone's dog.
[ Laughter ]
Like, we get pizza and we get
chairs but we don't get taxes,
you know?
Like we don't necessarily --
-All right, Mark, Mark,
I get it. I get it.
You don't get it,
but I have to ask, I mean,
how are you able to be
a financial consultant
if your advice is just
to not to do your taxes?
I mean, who are your clients?
-Donald Trump.
-Ah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
Mark Bream, everybody.
Mark Bream.
-Ah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, listen to this.
I heard about a new bowl
with a built-in wall that goes
between your milk
and your cereal so the cereal
doesn't get soggy.
[ Audience oohs ]
Or as one guy put it...
[ Imitating Trump ] "The cereal
should make the milk
pay for that wall."
[ Laughter ]
"No way."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get this. Police in Argentina
are in trouble for losing
over 1,000 pounds of marijuana
and then saying
the weed was eaten by mice.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, there's totally
a mouse out there like,
"I need cheese, bruh."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of animals, I read
that the green-haired turtle has
officially been added to
the endangered species list.
Have you --
this is a real thing.
Have you seen
the green-haired turtle?
Take a look at this thing.
It's real.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty crazy. Well, I guess it's
been feeling depressed
about being endangered,
so other animals are
trying to cheer it up.
Here's what some of them
had to say.
First, this blobfish said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And this next animal said..."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this monkey said...
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ] Oy!
-I heard that scientists say
there's currently a giant hole
on the surface of the sun,
but it's probably nothing
to worry about.
Anyway, happy Friday the 13th,
everybody. And...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally this week,
President Trump said that
Robert Mueller's investigation
is the reason America and Russia
have bad blood.
Trump's actually been talking
a lot about bad blood.
Bad blood, a lot. So I'll show
you what I mean. Watch this.
-♪♪ 'Cause, baby,
now we've got bad blood ♪♪
♪♪ You know it used
to be mad love ♪♪
♪♪ Take a look
what you've done ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause, baby, now we've
got bad blood, hey ♪♪
-We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!